bonjour
alors là c'est la zone où les clients
viennent récupérer leur commande celles
qui sont déjà tout près les clients font
leurs courses sur le drive tenue points
comme comme pour un drive classic ids
indique à quelle heure et quel jour ils
veulent venir récupérer leur commande et
nous on conditionne tout en fait toutes
leurs commandants des emballages
réutilisables donc soit des sacs en
toile soit des bocaux verre que le
client vient ensuite récupérer donc là
par exemple on avait super choco pops du
lauragais et et une fois que le client
vient récupérer sa commande
donc on lui livre dans sa voiture et en
même temps ils nous rapportent les
emballages réutilisables de sa commande
précédente qu'on va se charger de
nettoyer et de remettre dans le circuit
et pour les remercier de participer à
une économie circulaire on leur donne un
bon d'achat de 10 centimes par contenant
ramener qui peuvent cumuler en ondes
achats dans le magasin ils peuvent aussi
nous rapporter les contenants qu'ils ont
d'autres d'autres producteurs comme un
bouquet de sauce tomate ou un bocal de
confiture en récupère tous les déchets
d'emballage on les paye en amont puisque
ça compte pour 10 à 40% de du prix d'un
produit que lorsqu'on passe à la caisse
il ya on les paye aussi en aval puisque
le coût du traitement des déchets en
france et 7 milliards d'euros par an
donc on s'est dit il faut que la vente
de vrac la consommation en vrac se
développent et grandissent donc on s'est
dit on va associer la quintessence de la
simplicité de la consommation qui est le
drive avec une consommation zéro déchet
100% responsable et on a créé le drive
tous les produits que pierre jeanniot la
grogne des niches c'est son plus grand
plaisir
voilà parce qu'on vend des produits
alimentaires des produits cosmétiques et
des produits ménagers bien évidemment je
goûte pas les produits ménagers par
contre on les essayent les cosmétiques
c'est pareil par contre la grosse je me
fais plaisir je goûte tout donc ici par
exemple on a des supers limonade
artisanale qui viennent de l'aveyron des
bières aussi de l'aveyron de la haute
garonne de l'ariège vous avez l'eau 2000
a ici donc l'eau de millas c'est une
bière qui est fait à base de patates
douces et de sorgho d'occitanie
parce que au minimum 60 % de nos
produits soient issus d'un père email de
moins de 100 km autour de toulouse
voilà voilà donc c'est le cas pour les
produits que je viens de vous montrer
c'est aussi le cas pour ces produits là
c'est des concepts sans fait à revel en
haute-garonne la manière dont on choisit
nos produits on les classe selon trois
critères donc le premier c'est
conçoivent conçoit fourrure voilà soit
en vrac soit déjà dans des emballages
réutilisables comme des conserves en
bocaux verre par exemple ça c'est des
pots bébé de la haute garonne
ensuite le deuxième critère c'est le
local donc on essaye d'être locale quand
c'est possible donc typiquement ce qu'on
vous a présenté ces locales les conserve
ses locales les pâtes les lentilles les
haricots tous assez local et lorsque
c'est pas possible on va chercher un
petit peu plus loin mais on passe soit
en direct comme par exemple pour les
oranje
donc ça c'est des oranje qui viennent
d'espagne mais qui sont directs
producteurs en fait c'est un producteur
qui fait des supers orange bio c'est un
des leaders du bio en espagne qui fait
du bio plus bio que les contrats bio
espagnols donc on était toujours d'être
bio quand ça fait sens donc on n'est pas
dogmatique sur le bio mais par exemple
entre un kiwi qui est produit en
conventionnel dans le tarn et garonne et
un kiwi néo zélandais bio on vachon
aller vers le local sachant que c'est le
rôle de pierre qui est ingénieur agro du
coup et qui en capacité qui connaît qui
sait lire les procédés culture eau et
les soins qui ont été portées ou non aux
produits de faire ce choix on a plein
d'accessoires zéro déchet aussi pour
faciliter la transition des personnes
qui peut-être ne sont pas forcément
équipés au départ mais qui ont cette
volonté de consommer de façon plus
responsable donc elles peuvent aussi
s'équiper chez nous on a des gourdes qui
sont ben voilà qui sont une alternative
à la bouteille d'eau en plastique
classique il ya des pailles zéro déchet
ça fait toujours son petit effet à
l'apéro quand vous la sortez si ça
attise la curiosité des copains jeu
qu'on a par exemple à des petits savons
qu'ils sont faits par emeline elle
appelle ça des savons tous nus donc nous
ça nous a beaucoup plu du coup
et hop je vais passer de votre côté oh
oui ça va passer mais c'est bon c'est
bon là nickel je pense que de plus en
plus
zéro déchet trop de trucs sur emballés
c'est ridicule
merci mr voir qu'il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui 56 % des actifs dans la
région occitanie habite dans le
périurbain
ces gens là ils sont obligés de prendre
la voiture pour aller travailler
donc il faut aussi leur proposer une
solution pour consommer responsable
c'est pas réservé aux personnes qui
habitent en centre ville
l'idée du dos reis oui c'est vraiment
faciliter au maximum démocratiser le
zéro déchet pour tout le monde pour que
quand on a quand on fait quand on sort
du boulot et qu'on se dit j'ai pas fais
mes courses
on pense au drive tout lui est pas
forcément à se dire je vais faire une
bonne action consomme zéro déchet mais
je vais aller chez le directeur parce
que c'est normal et c'est hyper simple
[Musique]